It was a race against time to find four young Children who survived a plane crash in the
Colombian Amazon.
No,
no.
The discovery of the wreckage sparked a frantic search that transfixed the nation as
rescuers combed through the depths of inhospitable jungle for over a month,
a military leader who oversaw the search and the children's great uncle sat down with the
journal to provide a first hand account of the harrowing survival story.
Yeah.
The children's ordeal began early on May 1st when the engine of the small plane they were
traveling in,
cut out over virgin rainforest in southern Colombia.
The Cessna 206 fell plowed through trees and slammed into the jungle two
weeks after the crash.
Soon after indigenous volunteers located the wreckage.
Colombian army commandos arrived at the scene and found three lifeless bodies.
The pilot,
an indigenous leader and a young woman named Magdalena Muto.
The children's mother.
The plane's manifest showed that the four siblings,
two sisters,
ages 13 and nine,
a five year old boy and a baby girl had also been aboard,
but they were nowhere to be found.
Colombian armed forces,
General Pedro Sanchez who oversaw the rescue operation said soldiers
inspecting the crash scene,
noticed something hopeful,
the tail of the plane was intact.
Meanwhile,
the four siblings found themselves lost and alone in a forbidding environment,
an intense search code named operation hope was launched involving 11
aircraft,
113 commandos and 92 indigenous trackers,
many of whom fish and hunt in the region.
Soon after the plane was discovered,
the searchers said they found a baby bottle three miles from where the plane went down
in the days that followed.
They reported finding more clues,
scissors,
the tennis shoes of a small boy and a child's footprint in the mud.
Relatives in the country's army said that over the 40 days,
the Children wandered the rain forest.
They survived on the small supply of food,
they scavenged from the luggage that was on the plane as well as nuts and wild fruit found on
the forest floor.
When a group of indigenous trackers crisscrossed through the jungle on June 9th.
They noticed something,
photographs provided by the Colombian armed forces show soldiers tending to the Children.
They were lifted out by helicopter and taken to the small town of San Jose del Guaviare
in southern Colombia where the country's president said they received medical attention.
Relatives celebrated when news of the rescue came through
the next day.
The Children were flown to awaiting ambulances in Bogota and transferred to a military
hospital where doctors say they are surrounded by relatives and recovering
Sanchez attributes the children's survival to four factors.
The desire to live their strong immunity,
indigenous knowledge and good health.